il ya le président qui nous a rejoint
regardez comme il est beau regarder
comme il est chic notre président de ces
visites c'est vrai que franck a très tôt
dès que je suis arrivé sur ces 8 il
était déjà là bas on se connaissait un
petit peu avec francs capitaux puisque
travailler sur comédie avant et je me
rappelle que j'avais produit une
émission pour comédie juste avant et on
s'était rencontrés voilà on avait mangé
une pizza ensemble et tout de suite ça
avait collé et mon franck maintenant
c'est devenu mon frère vraiment mon
bonbon vraiment mais quand je dis mon
frère c'est pas comme s'ils allaient le
mans series
comme je ne sais pas c'est pas une
expression c'est vrai mon chéri ouais je
voulais leur père s'est joué voilà pour
les dix ans mon chéri tu es notre
président bien évidemment là comme ça on
en aura on n'aura plus jamais un mot
chéri est ce que c'est que ces heureux
de nous voir parce que c'est super je
suis super super émue de vous voir je
suis là je comprends par valérie gilles
les réalisateurs jean jacques franck
mathieu évidemment et et j'ai très ému
de voir sera ya un plaisir fou de la
voir ce soir je connais tous ces gens et
benjamin évidemment voilà je suis très
ému par mon franc convenir à tout le
monde ce soir je vais te scotché devant
ma télé je suis je suis évidemment
présent à tes côtés mon frérot je peine
d'amour tu es un génie de la télé je
pense que tous les gens qui vont
témoigner ce soir savent à quel point on
s'amuse depuis alors moi depuis huit ans
même si on s'est connus au démarrage 2
et sur france 4 mai mais quel plaisir de
travailler avec toi quelle folie qu'elle
quelles libertés quelle bonheur c'est
vraiment une grande joie sache là c'est
moi qui te remercier mon chat une grande
ferveur tout ce qu'on peut faire sur ces
vite c'est grâce à toi aussi grâce à
toutes les équipes
vinson pujol qu'on a deux on a des
équipes formidables damien hammouchi
julien lalande qu'on embrasse port aussi
qu'ils étaient avec nous dès le début
gérald brice viret bien entendu
toute l'équipe de ses huit dirais que
c'est une petite équipe pauline charme
tout ça tout les tous les sénateurs et
la plus belle caroline graffe ce qu'ils
ont valu grandclaude c'est des
personnalités exceptionnelles c'est des
gens extrêmement réactif très très dans
l'époque ils n'ont peur de rien ils
aiment ism l'adp archaïque et écopé et
et et c'est et c'est pour nous une
aventure télévisuelle absolument unique
on le sait tous et eon qui le ca et
c'est en grande partie grâce à toi
vraiment cette voie là non mais tu sais
on est dans une période de confinement
le puits soit avec nous tous les soirs
c'est un peu notre raison d'être en ce
moment les gens témoigne me témoigne à
longueur de journée de l'affection et
l'amour de portes et et moi je te
connais je sais qui tu étais un homme de
grand coeur
voilà il ya plein de choses que tu fais
sans les caméras ils font des choses
absolument merveilleuse tué à la fois à
un génie de la télévision parce que
au-delà de l'émission que tu produis tu
es tu es totalement obsédée par les
audiences on discute dans la
programmation même des autres chaînes en
s'étonnant tu es mort ça c'est pour
francky avec les présidents de ces huit
années n'ont pas directeur général tu es
président vous chérissez le président
est-ce que vous avez des questions à
poser ou un truc à dire à franck appelé
tôt parce que c'est quand même rare
d'avoir un président comme ça je le dis
franchement je dis pas parce que c'est
parce que c'est au delà de vos président
je vous dis aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
un ami c'est vraiment un ami très proche
tranquille le sait voilà c'est donner un
ami est-ce que vous avez quelque chose
des choses à lui dire
gilles verdez moi j'ai une remarque sur
sa personnalité
il ya quelque chose d'exceptionnel qui
colle exactement à touche pas à mon
poste c'est sa finesse humaine alors
j'ai pas l'expertisé pour juger de ses
qualités professionnelles fantastique
feffs humainement à chaque fois moi il
est venu me dire des petites choses
sensibles et censés tu dois améliorer ça
tu pourrais changer ça là c'était bien
et à chaque fois ça tombe juste les
finesses d' analyse il fait vraiment les
grands hommes de télé mois franck jeu
franchement je voulais te dire
humainement je t'apprécie énormément tu
compte beaucoup beaucoup pour moi merci
d'être là toujours à mes côtés
merci gilles sait vraiment si je suis
très touché parce que tu aimes bien bon
et bien sûr et c'est vrai que et gilles
et sincère parce que sinon et puis il
est sincère et puis surtout je te
rappelle qu'il compte se marier avec
fatou l'année prochaine donc c'est
important de voilà on va matthieu
delormeau matière mathieu le mariage en
direct
marianne mathieu parce que mathieu
mathieu je vais dire la vérité je vais
dire aux téléspectateurs
merci à toi t'as vu ta vu beaucoup de
chaînes dans mes siret et et producteur
je vois beaucoup de chaînes tu as
travaillé sur nrj 12 a travaillé
longtemps sur nrj12 qui est une chaîne
mois que j'adore en plus nrj 12 est gelé
je le dis franchement j'adore chrétienne
et j'adore parce que ils font voilà ils
sont pas ils ont ils essaient de faire
leur truc
et ils font des trucs voilà il crée des
choses c'est pour ça que je les aime
beaucoup et mine de rien qu'est-ce que
tu retiens parce que quand tu vois
patron comme un président comme francs
capitaux
je crois que toi tu dis on est c 8 c'est
un autre monde mines en attisant de tpm
paix dont huit ans sur ces vite je crois
qu'on n'aurait pas pu les faire ailleurs
avec autant de liberté mais surtout ce
que je retiens un bon jour à tout ce que
je retiens surtout c'est que j'essaie ya
deux types de patrons ya les patrons qui
aimeraient être à l'antenne publique si
je sois bras ça donne souvent des gens
un peu aigri et il est patron qui rêve
pas d'être à l'antenne mais qui aime les
animateurs avec tout ce qu'il ya de bien
être pas bien et problèmes d'ego de
machins et tout ça et ces gens-là ça
donne déjà très compréhensif et franck
que tu t'appelles maîtres de leurs
mollets temps un petit chroniqueur ou
hanouna il sera face à bord sylla et it
écoute et il est patient et il s'est
parfois on parle de nous on est là pour
aller à magna met toujours la porte
ouverte
il est patient ilan provoque relancer la
machine et ça c'est pas hyper touchant
et et voilà je parle pas du coût du coup
du côté producteurs je parle du côté
patron ou à l'essec de tendons quand on
frappe à sa porte us pour les connards
de plaintes pour les ramener au malheur
va l'ouvrir et la fin d'un quart d'heure
il va l'écouter et ça c'est très
touchant
jamais mathieu vous avez du talent
les amours vous avez vous avez tout cela
du talent sincèrement évidemment que
vous écoutez c'est la moindre des choses
parce que vous êtes des hypersensibles
parce que vous êtes des gens qui se
remettent en question en permanence et
et c'est mon métier de faire ça aussi
et puis et puis même si parfois je peux
avoir des mois un peu dure vis-à-vis de
vous vous le savez que c'est que de la
bienveillance de ma part c'est vous êtes
talentueux ce gentil val talentueux vous
vous seriez pas là j'en ai vu passer
tellement badji toi et voilà qu'on vous
montre comme sa présidente y est voilà
qui répond à toutes les questions
voilà c'est pour ses 10 ans voulez vous
offrir aussi cette séquence à vous qui
nous regardent et chez vous pour vous
changer les idées
benjamin castaldi toi qu'a fait franck m
en guise de rien avec tact hallucine ou
pas de ce qu'on fait sur ces huit mois
j'ai dû signer moi je le suis surtout de
2 franck c'est vrai que franck il a une
qualité et je pas tout tout vous
raconter ce qu est ce qui m'a dit
auront-elles mais c'est vrai qu'au début
il a été très honnête avec moi je sais
que cette époque la série de l'étang dès
que la chaîne n'est pas forcément
satisfait de ce que je faisais et les
lettres ne veut pas dire benjamin si tu
continues comme ça ça va pas le faire et
quand j'ai réussi et compris et démons
rôle sur la chaîne il a filmé a fait un
bel hommage en direct 8 cyril c'est
parce que c'est rare d'avoir un
président qui voulait dire franchement
est nul à chier
l'europe du toit et qui vous dit et est
nul à chier mais tu as compris ce qu'on
me demande et toi et maintenant tu vas
toi et ça vous dit en télé on vous dit
toujours tu es le plus grand que je ne
veux plus formidable mais rarement
reprends-toi fait quatre ans qu'il est
là vous dire des choses là avec moi en
tous les cas et il m'a fait beaucoup
pour rester leader nuit kousséri parce
que c'est vrai que moi je suis arrivé un
peu et même en gueule et et tu sais à
chaque fois à chaque fois que j'étais
très content de pouvoir et et que
j'avais tendance alors je peux le dire
parce que je te le disais en direct mais
j'en parle investi avec cyril s'il était
élu été le premier à défendre toujours
même si je l'aï dit je sais qu'ils en
tiraient même chose que moi je te
défendrai toujours pas ce que tu es mon
frère si les téléspectateurs ne rejoigne
vous faites partie de la famille tpm
paie depuis dix ans maintenant on
voulait voilà vous offrir pour cet
anniversaire une émission petit peu
spécial vous savez voilà on n'a pas bien
sûr toutes les images ne peut pas vous
offrir tous les happenings qu'on
pourrait y aura des petits happenings
des petits défis y aura plein de jour au
téléphone et vous voulez vous offrir
aussi la fanny tpm paie tous les gens
qui sont derrière dont notre président
voilà qu'est la france capitaux privés
une vraie famille cyril car l on doit
dire c'est une famille avec des
spectateurs aussi agréments qui sont
beaucoup d'amour à mais les fans 12 on
les adore ils sont exceptionnels de
fidélité de deux ils critiquent ils sont
comme nous ils sont d'une sincérité et
les téléspectateurs klein c'est vrai que
je le vois il nous donne toujours les
bons conseils sur les missions et ses
sacs et ses ex ac exception valérie est
un truc à dire voilà parce que pour la
liberté bidoit ça fait huit ans qu'on
est sûr c'est vite et c'est vrai qu'on a
connu et on va connaître encore j'espère
plein d'émotion a c'est vrai que c'est
incroyable oui oui non ce qui est
surtout est-ce que ce que disaient mes
petits camarades par rapport à franck
c'est l'humanité de ce rang qu'ils ne
considèrent pas simplement comme des
machines à animer mais comme des êtres
humains
et ça c'est dans une relation
professionnelle c'est assez incroyable
d'avoir ça c'est à dire de ne pas
simplement faut que tu fasses ti que tu
te mettes comme ça et que tu parles
comme si tu parles comme ça ici c'est
s'adapter à la personnalité de chacun
avec énormément bienveillance d'écouté
en même temps il sait très bien ce qu'il
a envie ce dont il a envie ils marchent
main dans la main savait exactement vous
voulez qu'on aille mais en même temps
j'avais avec cette fois-là il est quand
même aussi aller coûte aussi très
désireux de comprendre et pourquoi où on
en est nous personnellement pour avancer
ensemble et ça c'est absolument un luxe
complet que je ne connaissais pas moi
dans le monde de la télévision c'est un
vrai luxe et et par ailleurs c'est un
des patrons de chaînes qui ont tous les
délires dévoiler son jeu franck ouvrie
de faire un gros bisou ce soir merci mon
frère scènes d'amour vraiment me manquer
à bientôt
bats toi aussi on t'aime fort mais je
merci merci nous faire quitter comme ça
tu sais qu'on t'aime fort